la prochaine fois que vous envoyer un
texto à la personne que vous aimez au
lieu de lui mettre un petit coeur pensé
à lui mettre un petit cerveau
[Musique]
lorsque vous tombez amoureux en fait le
premier organe impliqué c'est votre
cerveau dans votre cerveau va y avoir
toute une activité électrique et
chimiques qui vont se mettre en place et
envoyés tout un tas de petits messages
d'ordre en fait au reste du corps qui va
avoir pour conséquence des réactions
physiologiques le coeur qui s'accélère
on a un petit peu chaud on n'arrive plus
à dormir la nuit parce qu'on pense à
l'autre personne
si on s'amuse à regarder le cerveau d'un
sujet amoureux par exemple grâce à des
techniques d'imagerie cérébrale on va
avoir plusieurs zones qui s'activent
[Musique]
ce circuit de récompense il n'est pas
spécifique de l'amour il intervient en
fait pour n'importe quelle source de
plaisir que vous pouvez ressentir dans
la vie de tous les jours manger boire
dormir et même les drogues et l'alcool
peuvent faire dysfonctionné ce circuit
de la récompense
d'ailleurs il est intéressant de noter
que même dans la relation amoureuse
lorsque la passion est beaucoup trop
forte et parfois qu'on n'a pas le change
avec le partenaire ce circuit de la
récompense peu dysfonctionné et nous
conduire à un comportement addictif
vis-à-vis de l'autre voire destructeurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notamment le cortex préfrontal qui nous
sert à la prise de décision rationnelle
c'est bien dommage mais aussi l'amygdale
cérébrale qui est impliqué dans le
ressenti de la peur parfois des émotions
négatives du jugement
autrement dit votre cerveau est devenu
aveugle il est ivre quelque part et on
ne voit plus les défauts de lettres
qu'on aime en fait on les verra plus
tard
[Musique]
la dopamine c'est l'hormone de la
motivation et du désir est une hormone
qui va nous aider à passer à l'action si
par exemple on veut conquérir un être
convoité mais qui va aussi augmenter la
sensation de plaisir ressenti d'un autre
côté on a la sérotonine qui sert de
modulateurs notamment pour avoir un
petit peu plus de sérénité
généralement au début de la relation on
manque un peu de sérotonine ce qui peut
faire que le début d'une relation
s'accompagne d'une fragilité
émotionnelle
enfin on a les endorphines endorphines
signifie morphine endogène ça veut dire
que votre corps produit ses propres
morphine qui ont un effet un petit peu
fort ''sans antidouleur qui fait qu'on a
c'est justement cette forêt du début de
la relation et enfin on ne peut pas
parler d'amour sans parler de la fameuse
ocytocine alors est souvent appelée
hormone de lamoura torse un peu en abus
de langage elle intervient dans toutes
les interactions sociales où l'on
s'attache avec quelqu'un c'est aussi
l'hormone de l'empathie et en gros
l'ocytocine si vous êtes un petit peu le
ciment de la relation durable
[Musique]
on entend souvent que l'amour dure trois
ans c'est vrai mais c'est faux en fait
ça dépend de vous si vous laissez votre
relation ce s'ancrer dans les habitudes
du quotidien effectivement il se peut
que petit à petit le circuit de la
récompense se désactive et vous allez
entrer dans une phase de lassitude
si bien que la relation va sans doute se
terminer pour beaucoup ça dure trois ans
pour certains cette pour d'autres
peut-être plus on dit souvent qu'il faut
entretenir la flamme en réalité
entretenir la flamme c'est à voir les
petites attentions des petites surprises
du quotidien avec l'être aimé qui vont
permettre d'entretenir les sécrétions
répétait d'ocytocine et de dopamine ce
qui va permettre en fait quelque part
d'entretenir le circuit de la récompense
de votre partenaire et l'autre
[Musique]
vous décidez pas de tomber amoureux
l'amour ça arrive comme ça c'est
incontrôlable et ça n'est dans le
cerveau ce qui est fantastique dans
l'espèce humaine c'est qu'on a notamment
avec le cortex cérébral la capacité plus
tard d'intellectualiser et du coup de
faire évoluer cette manière d'aimer si
bien qu'on le voit d'ailleurs l'amour
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué
qui dépasse de loin la neurochimie et la
biologie
il ya aussi tout l'aspect psychologique
mais on observe aussi quand on voit
toute la diversité des sexualités qui
existe dans l'espèce humaine
finalement le mystère de l'amour est
encore entier il ya des tonnes de choses
à découvrir